[Music]
if there's one thing that Star Wars
Battlefront 2 accomplishes well it's the
feeling of being in the exciting
universe of the legendary film series
serving up the greatest hits of all
things Star Wars the follow-up to dices
2015 multiplayer focused game presents a
greater package of content over its
predecessor but overall it's weighed
down by an overbearing and convoluted
progression system that doesn't seem to
value the average players time obscuring
an otherwise solid Star Wars experience
set across the backdrop of the entire
Star Wars saga Battlefront 2 expands the
scope of its galactic battles to great
effect from taking part in aerial
dogfights above Kamino to raiding the
Death Star - and escaping before its
destruction
the sequel puts its 14 Maps set across
the 40-year history of the series to
good use showing a clear difference in
aesthetics and tone from one time period
to the next
what's the plan come on keep getting
started for your snake the rebel can't
learn about on reason cinder
alike the first battlefront the sequel
contains a narrative driven
single-player campaign showing the fall
of the Empire and the eventual dawn of
the first order you take on the role of
iDEN versio commander of the Imperial
Special Forces outfit and Ferno squad
she normally works to undermine rebel
forces with covert missions and other
forms of espionage but after the fall of
the second Death Star her loyalties to
the Empire is tested when an
increasingly desperate Imperial Army
takes drastic measures to ensure its
future but they're not cool for you come
on diverse here is our target one of
them yes why the entire planet and its
people they're they're loyal to the
Empire the Emperor commands it will
purge this planet and others fear shall
spread and the galaxy will remember who
is in control commands while the brisk
four to five hour campaign features some
strong writing and performances from his
cast with some standout levels that show
off the visual lustre and diversity of
locations within the universe the
potential of its Imperial point-of-view
soon becomes lost falling into some
rather predictable twists the story
eventually turns into a familiar by the
number Star Wars adventure where the
good guys and bad guys are clearly
defined and with the lead up to the
final acts confrontation that signposted
from a mile away
if the Empire's here what I sensed was
true there must be something special
about this place
on occasion the campaign jumps to levels
that feature familiar faces adding some
moments of levity to the story those fun
and refreshing as they can be they come
off a bit too much like fanservice
leading Ida and versio to stand in the
shadow of others this is made worse by
an abrupt ending that teases future
updates to the campaign instead of
delivering a strong conclusion for its
hero's journey with that said the
campaign does a fairly decent job of
showing the internal strife within the
Empire's ranks even allowing you to
explore an imperial civilization on
ITINs homeworld of bardos but overall it
falls a bit short of making it a
remarkable journey for its characters
outside of the campaign and massive
multiplayer battles there are side modes
that offer some interesting diversions
the Arcade Mode makes a return featuring
themed levels where you battle AI BOTS
as classic light and dark side
characters
moreover the fan-favorite heroes vs.
villains mode is back letting players
cut loose with their favorite characters
cutting out unnecessary filler players
can choose their unlocked characters and
compete in four and four battles in over
the top and ridiculous fashion of your
time will be spent on the Galactic front
lines in battlefront two's multiplayer
while the 40 player conquest game type
galactic assault will likely be the most
popular game mode the upgraded
Starfighter assault deserves some
recognition
now with more responsive and tighter
controls for maneuvering your vessels
the aerial focus mode features
battlefront tuesd most intense missions
along with some stellar visual and sound
design the large-scale battles have the
same exciting flow as Star Wars as most
iconic fights where one heroic action
can turn the tide of a conflict another
victory for the first-order
your set of troopers starfighter classes
and hero characters can be boosted up
with star cards by amplifying stats
adding bonus attributes and even giving
characters alternate loadouts such as
replacing a heavy troopers energy shield
for a grenade launcher the number of
ways you can modify your characters is
impressive
[Music]
unfortunately this is where battlefront
two's multiplayer progression begins to
show its cracks getting a handle the
many systems gates and subtle nuances
therein can be confusing and off-putting
after each battle you'll collect
experience for your overall rank and
also credits to use for purchasing loot
crate's in the in-game store by relying
on randomly yielded weapons resources
and star cards of varying grades
battlefront - largely ties its
progression to dice rolls while you can
acquire an upgrade star cards on your
own by using crafting components found
from loot crate's this also leads into
the general problem of gating to upgrade
a card you have to ensure that your
class level and overall multiplayer
ranking meets certain standards while
also spending the fruits of your labor
on loot crate's for more resources and
cards simply focusing on the characters
and classes you like to play isn't
enough and the system in place all too
easily puts walls in front of you due to
the randomness and the inherent
dependence on the loot crate's
progression is often dictated by what
these results are this steers you away
from the classes you like and more
annoyingly results in cards for hero
characters you have yet to unlock this
is all made worse by the cumbersome menu
system which prompts you to exit out of
multiplayer games to collect your
rewards from milestones and challenges
while also obscuring vital information
such as player rank and class data
shortly before battlefront 2's official
launch ea removed its premium currency
due to negative reaction from the early
access period in the form of crystals
this particular resource which we were
able to buy and packs up to $100 was
used to circumvent credits for
purchasing loot boxes while this removal
may seem like a welcome change the rest
of the progression system remains
unaltered leaving you with fewer options
to deal with an already steep ride the
grind in Battlefront 2 will force you to
reconcile with the fact that the time
you invest in the game won't always be
rewarded with progress or at least in
the way you want but above all the
biggest problem with the system is that
it's never clearly explained while
you'll eventually come to understand the
value of credits and other resources
this realization comes as a result of
how little the game offers them in
addition to the arcade boat time gaining
mission rewards upon completion many of
the rewards from battle and milestone
challenges offer scraps for the
sometimes large efforts though the
prices of heroes have been significantly
slashed trying to save up for them is
still a large exercise in patience and
frustration as stockpiling your credits
it means you won't be able to buy the
expensive
Vital Luke rates in this way Battlefront
to plants itself in the same territory
as free to play games with much of its
content and characters tucked away
behind progression walls randomized loot
boxes and gameplay timers above all it
ends up doing a disservice to the core
gameplay itself which can still provide
those solid moments of enjoyment despite
the looming presence of its progression
systems many of these issues related to
the meta game fall by the wayside when
you're in the thick of battle as you're
taking part in the massive struggle
throughout the many locales in the Star
Wars universe while its main narrative
feels unresolved and the general loop of
the multiplayer carries a number of
issues Battlefront 2 still manages to
evoke the same sense of joy and
excitement found in the core of what the
series is all about but as it stands the
biggest hurdle that battlefront 2 will
need to overcome for its simultaneous
attempts to balance complex progression
with the genuine feeling of
accomplishments is deciding on what type
of game it wants to be
[Music]
Oh